Skillshare is a learning community...
...where people can learn real-world skills from anyone, anywhere, all over the world.
When I happened upon Skillshare, I was sort of blown away by this idea...
...that learning can mean so many different things to so many different people.
We started with offline local classes...
...where people can just raise their hand and say they wanna teach something...
...and gather people locally in their community to teach them that skill.
Before going online, we really studied the local classes...
...and the behavior of the students and the teachers...
...and we took that behavior to inform the classroom model online.
The real hurdle or challenge, if you wanna say it that way,...
...was getting people to learn from total strangers...
...who weren't accredited in any specific thing.
Learning how to make fried chicken from just a great fried chicken maker...
...as opposed to the chef of XY and Z restaurant...
...is a little bit of a paradigm shift.
But once it took off, it took off.
The premise of Skillshare is to learn real-world skills...
...so not academic, History 101.
This is, "I want to learn how to cook."
"I wanna learn how to make jewelry."
"I wanna learn design."
I don't think that Skillshare will ever replace traditional education.
That's definitely not the goal.
The goal is to shake things up a little bit.